[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث مميزه
البدايه من عاصمه
حيث تظاهر اليوم الاف من انصار الانقلاب
قرب القاعده الفرنسيه تظاهر ضد باريس
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران وهذه الصور حيث
افادت وكاله فارس نقلا عن مصدر وصفته
بالمطلع انا وفقا للاتفاق بين طهران و
واشنطن لتبادل السجناء فقد تم بالفعل نقل
اصول ايران المجمده من كوريا الجنوبيه وتم
ايداعها في بنك بسويسرا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
زادت اعلان الصفقه الامريكيه الايرانيه
البيت الابيض يقول ان قيودا ستفرض على ما
يمكن لايران فعله بالاموال المفرشه عنها
ومصدر ايراني يقول لوكاله فارس ان اصول
ايران المجمده بكوريا الجنوبيه اودعت
بمصرف سويسري وانها ستحول الى مصرفين
قطريين خلال ايام دوله قطر تؤمن ايمانا
تاما في البدايه بضروره حل الخلافات
بالطرق السلميه والخارجيه القطريه تقول
للجزيره ان الاتفاق الامريكي الايراني
دليل على امكانيه تسويه خلافات المنطقه
بالحوار وخطوه يؤمل ان تفضي الاتفاق بشان
الملف النووي
رغم تاكيدها على اولويه الدبلوماسيه عن
اجتماع لقاده جيوش الاسبوع المقبل بوضع
خطه تدخل عسكري محتمل في النيجر موسكو
تدخل على خط الازمه بتحذير من عواقب اي
تحرك عسكري
والاف من انصار الانقلاب يتظاهرون قرب
القاعده الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
بعد اقرار بصعوبات في جبهات القتال القوات
الروسيه تؤكد تعزيز مواقعها في شمال شرقي
اوكرانيا وتستهدف غربها بالصواريخ
يبطل جميع رؤساء مراكز التجنيد العسكري في
انحاء البلاد بدعوى الفساد
على وقع معارك ضاريه في الخرطوم ومدن اخرى
الخارجيه السودانيه ترهل العوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات بانسحاب قوات الدعم السريع من
منازل المدنيين والامم المتحده تطالب
بتامين وصول المساعدات لجميع انحاء
السودان بما في ذلك كل فان
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم المسارات المرتقبه
للازمه في النيجر في ظل الاعلان عن اجتماع
مقبل لرؤساء اركان الجيوش المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا المعروفه
اختصارا باسمك واصل الاجتماع سيكون خلال
ايام الاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي الذي
يقول برايكم ما هي مالات اجتماع اكواس
المقبل بشان النينجا نحو 29% توقعوا
الاعلان عن تدخل عسكري في النيجر فيما ذهب
قرابه 38 بالمئه توقعوا مواصله التشاور
بشان هذه الازمه اما نحو 33 بالمئه فراوا
انه سيتم الاعلان عن عقوبات اضافيه ضد
النيجر
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد تحذيرات من كارثه بيئيه محتمله الامم
المتحده تعلن انتهاء عمليه سحب النفط من
الناقله صافر المتداعيه قباله اليمن
[موسيقى]
البدايه من اتفاق واشنطن وطهران على صفقه
لتبادل اطلاق السجناء والغاء تجميد
مليارات الدولارات من عائدات النفط
الايراني فقد قال البيت الابيض انه سيكون
على اطلاع كامل على وجهه الاموال
الايرانيه المفرج عنها بينما نقلت وكاله
فارس الايرانيه عن مصدر وصفته بالمطلع ان
اصول ايران المجمده من كوريا الجنوبيه قد
اودعت في بنك بسويسرا وقال المصدر ان
اذاعه الاموال في بنكين قطريين سيتم خلال
الايام القليله المقبله لتحول الى حسابات
ايرانيه في بنوك قطريه وقالت وكاله فارس
ان البنك المركزيه الايراني ستكون له كامل
الصلاحيه في شراء السلع الاساسيه والادويه
وانه وفق الصفقه ستنقل اصول ايرانيه من
المصرف العراقي للتجاره الى حسابات
ايرانيه في دولتين بالمنطقه
تفاصيل الاتفاق الامريكيه الايرانيه الذي
تم بواسطه قطريه وسياقاته نتابعها فيما
يلي
صفقه امريكيه ايرانيه افراج عن اموال
وودائعه للطيران وتبادل السجناء امريكيين
وايرانيين بواسطه قطريه ما هي حيثيات
الاتفاق الذي قد يزيد من التعاون
الدبلوماسي بحسب المطلعين عليه
الاعلان عن الاتفاق اتى بصوره مفاجئه وينص
وفقا للخارجيه الايرانيه على الافراج عن
عشره مليارات دولار امريكيه هي اصول
واموال ايرانيه مدعه في كوريا الجنوبيه
واموال مدعه في بنك التجاره العراقي هي
عباره عن ثمن نفط اشتراه العراق من ايران
تنقل الاموال المجمده بعدها من كوريا
الجنوبيه الى سويسرا قبل تحويلها الى حساب
في دوله قطر وستخصص المبالغ المفرج عنها
لاغراض الانسانيه ومحدوده بحسب منسق
الاتصالات بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كيربي حيث ست مراقبتها للتاكد من
استخدامها فقط في مجالات الغير خاضعه
للعقوبات مثل الدواء والغذاء بحسب مقاله
صحيفه
وسيكون للولايات المتحده ودوله قطر
ومنظمات الاغاثه حق النقض على اي طلب لسحب
اموال من تلك الحسابات
دوله قطر كانت دائما صديقا رائعا في قضايا
عديده ونحن ممتنون ازاء الدعم الذي حصلنا
عليه من قطر في هذه المفاوضات على وجه
الخصوص اذا لم تكن الصفقه لتتم دون دخول
وسيط
على ان تبادر ايجابيا بوضع عدد من الضوابط
الواقعيه والمبادرات الايجابيه للطرفين
حتى تصل لهذا هذا النوع من التوافق ما بين
الطرفين وتحقيق الغايات المنشوده من وراء
هذا الات
تغيب الارقام الرسميه لحجب الاموال
الايرانيه المجمده في الخارج لكن ارقاما
غير رسميه تشير الى وجود ما بين 22 و 30
مليار دولار مجمده في الصين وهي اموال
ايرانيه نقلت من دول اخرى ولا يمكن
تحويلها الى ايران بسبب العقوبات وقرابه
احد عشر مليار دولار في العراق وسبعه
مليارات دولار في كوريا الجنوبيه ومليار
و600 مليون دولار في اليابان صفقه تبادل
السجناء هذه ليست الاولى من نوعها سبق
لاداره اوباما ان توصلت الى صفقه افرجت
ايران بموجبها عن خمسه امريكيين بينما
افرجت واشنطن عن سبعه ايرانيين صفقه ثانيه
تمت برعايه سويسريه في عهد ترامب حيث
افرجت واشنطن عن الاكاديميه الايراني
مسعود سليماني مقابل افراج طهران عن
الباحث الامري كي
وفي العام الموالي افرجت ايران عن الجندي
الامريكي السابق مايكل وايت مقابل افراج
واشنطن عن العالمين الايرانيين مجيد طاهري
وسيرس عسكري
معنا من واشنطن عضو مجلس الامن القوميه
الامريكيه السابق ومن طهران محمد مرندي
المستشار الاعلامي للوفد الايراني المفاوض
في فيينا اهلا بضيفينا نبدا من واشنطن سيد
اراث عندما يقول البيت الابيض بانه ستكون
هناك قيود على اوجه صرف الاموال الايرانيه
ماذا يعني ذلك
الوقت لا نعرف كل التفاصيل
المتعلقه ما الذي جرى الاتفاق عليه بالضبط
بشكل عام يتوقع ان هذا يعني ان هذه
الاموال ستستخدم لامور مثل شراء الادويه
والمواد الانسانيه
المطلوبه
والتي يحتاجونها لمساعده الناس في ايران
ولكن الى ان تحصلنا المزيد معلومات
لا استطيع ان اؤكد على اي شيء في انتظار
المزيد من المعلومات هل تتوقع ان هناك
اليه متفق عليها بين طهران وواشنطن في هذا
الموضوع
ان هذا هو السبب ان الامواسه تمر بطريقه
معقده جدا تنقل الى سويسرا اولا وبعد ذلك
تنقل الى الدوحه قبل ان تصل الى ايران هذه
الاليه للتاكد من انها ستستخدم للاغراض
المقصوده وليس لاي غرض يتناقض مع العقوبات
المفروضه في المقابل هنا نسال ضيفنا سيد
محمد مرندي في طهران في المقابل البنك
المركزي الايراني يقول بانه ستكون له كامل
الصلاحيه في
اقتناء السلع الاساسيه والادويه من من هذه
الاموال هل فعلا ستكون الصوره بهذا الشكل
نعم
هذا تحديدا ما سيحدث من الواضح
اداره بايدن لا تريد ان يتم النظر اليها
من قبلي انصاري ترامب او ترامب نفسي او
يتم تقديمها من قبل انصار ترامب او ترامب
على انها اداره ضعيفه بالتالي هي ستحاول
ان تضع نوعا من الفبركه حول هذا الامر لكن
بالتاكيد هذه هي اموال ايرانيه تم تجميدها
بطريقه غير قانونيه وهنالك الكثير ممن فقد
حياتهم من مرضى السرطان ومن المرضى الذين
نحتاج زرع اعضاء
توفوا وفقدوا حياتهم بعدم وجوده الخدمات
الطبيه والتي كانت
يتم استخدامها هذه الاموال هذه الاموال
ستعطى الى البنك المركزي الايراني وسائل
يستخدمونها بالطريقه التي يرونها مناسبه
الشيء المهم ان هذه خطوه خطوه واحده الى
الامام الايرانيون اطلقوا
عدد من الامريكيين الذين خرقوا القانون في
ايران والولايات المتحده ستطلق صراحه
ايرانيين كانوا يعملون
من اجل تخطي العقوبات الامريكيه في اماكن
مختلفه في العالم ولاسباب اخرى اذا بامكان
هذه الخطوه الاولى ان تكون خطوه جيده
لتحقيق تطور اضافي مستقبلا لدينا
المفاوضات حصلت السنه الماضيه حول
البرنامج النووي اقتربنا جدا من التواصلي
الى اتفاق وتوصلنا الى نص نهائي وجزف
براقا لان من طالب ايران
معقوله وكان هنالك الانتخابات النصفيه
وانسحب بعض من ذلك الوقت لم نتحرك اي خطوه
نحو اتجاه هذه الخطوه الاخيره بالتالي
نامل ان هذا سيكون يخلق نوعا من الزخم
لاتخاذ خطوات المستقبليه مثمره هذا الامل
على ان هذه الخطوه الاولى السيد ايرث يمكن
ان تعقبها خطوات اخرى هل تراه املا في
محله
لان هذه مؤشر ايجابي بان الحكومتين يتخذان
اجراءات في هذا المجال
والاجراءات التي اتخذت هي بنائه وفي هذه
الحاله
لمده تؤثر عليها او توقفها السياسه وكما
قال الضيف الاخر
عندما كنا
نقتربا احياء الاتفاق النووي حصلت امور
سياسيه عقدت الامر انا انا اقول ان الجانب
الايراني هو الذي ادخل هذه الجوانب
السياسيه في الولايات المتحده فعلت كل ما
في وسعها
ولكن ايضا يمكنك اختلاف في هذا المهم
عندما تستبعد السياسه احيانا المصالح
الوطنيه هي الاهم هنا نرى ان عندما تتصرف
كل دوله بموجب مصالحها فانا خطوات ايجابيه
ونعمل انعسات تتحسن هل هل ترى فيما جرى
سيد ايرث
خطوه هامه على الاقل عن طريق على طريق
بناء ثقه معينه بين طهران واشنطن بعد
سنوات من الشك المتبادل
اعتقد اننا سنرى خطوات ايجابيه يتم
اتخاذها فيما يتعلق بالاصول الايرانيه
المجمده في كوريا الجنوبيه والتي تم
تجميدها وكذلك في الاموال في العراق على
الرغم من انني اوافق مع ضيفك في ان هذه
خطوه اولى وعلينا ان ننتظر ونرى ما الذي
سيحدث حقيقه ان الازمه في اوروبا والحرب
في اوروبا بالنسبه الاقتصاديه وقضايا
داخليه داخل الولايات المتحده بين انصار
ترامب وبين معارضيه وبالتاكيد قضيه الصين
وافريقيا هنالك الكثير من الامور التي
تحصل بشكل متسارع الان الامريكيون ربما
سيرغبون بوضع ملف الايراني في مكان ما
بالتالي لا باستطاعتهم ان يركزوا بشكل
اكبر على اماكن اخرى في العالم الايرانيون
اذا
اتخذ الامريكيون القرارات الصحيحه وربما
تلبوا المطالب الايرانيه بالحد الادنى
سيتم احراز تقدم لكن السياسه معقده
والعالم يتغير بشكل متسارع للغايه بالتالي
من الصعب جدا التنبؤ بمن بما سيحدث خلال
الاشهر القادمه لكن كما قلت هذه خطوه مهمه
باي حاله من الاحوال شكرا جزيلا لك يا سيد
محمد مرندي من طهران شكرا لك من واشنطن
سيد جون ايرث
على سعيد اخر نقلت صحيفه عن مصادر مطلعه
ان ايران ابطات بشكل كبير وتيره تراكم
اليورانيوم المخصب بدرجه قريبه لتصنيع
الاسلحه وذلك في خطوه قد تساهم في تخفيف
التوترات مع الولايات المتحده واستئناف
محادثات اوسع نطاقا بشان برنامجها النووي
واضافت الصحيفه نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين
واوروبيين انه تم ابلاغ ايران انها اذا
خفضت التوترات خلال فصل الصيف فان الدول
الغربيه على استعدادا حينها لاجراء
محادثات واسعه بما في ذلك تلك المتعلقه
بالبرنامج النموي وبحسب المصادر فان جهود
خفض التصعيد اذا اثمرت فقد يلتقي الجانبان
الامريكي والايراني في سبتمبر ايلول
المقبل على هامش اجتماعات الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
المتحدث باسم المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا اكواس ان قاده جيوش المجموعه
سيجتمعون الاسبوع المقبل لوضع الخطط
اللازمه لتدخل عسكري محتمل في النيجر جاء
ذلك بعد حديثه مسؤولا نيجيري ومصدر في جيش
ساحل العاج ان الاجتماع سيعقد غدا السبت
في غانا
وفي ضم ذلك تدخل موسكو على خط الازمه فقد
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان التدخل العسكري
المحتمل في النيجر سيؤدي لمواجهه مطوله
وسيزعزع الاستقرار في منطقه الساحل
والصحراء حسب تعبير الخارجيه الروسيه
واضاف البيان ان موسكو ترحب بجهود الوساطه
التي تقوم بها مجموعه اكواس لانهاء الازمه
هذا وتستند مجموعه اكواس في نقاشاتها بشان
تدخل عسكري محتمل في النيجر الى
بروتوكولات داخليه وضعتها على مدار عقود
رغم ان خطوه التدخل لا تزال محل تباين بين
الدول الاعضاء في العرض التالي نتعرف على
البروتوكولات المنظمه لهذه التدخلات
العسكريه لاكواس
مع تصاعد التطورات في النيجر تتجه الانظار
الى مجموعه ايكواس بانتظار حسم قرارها
تجاه التدخل العسكري هناك مستنده في ذلك
الى بروتوكولات داخليه للمجموعه وضعتها
على مدار عقود ففي عام
1978 جرت توقيع على بروتوكول عدم الاعتداء
وجاء بمثابه اعلان مبادئ ولم يتضمن اي
مواد لها علاقه بالتدخلات العسكريه واشار
في ماده الاولى الى ضروره امتناع الدول
الاعضاء عن استخدام القوه او النيل من
استقلاليه او سياده اي دوله عضو في
المجموعه في عام
1981 وقع دول المجموعه بروتوكولا المساعده
الجماعيه في حاله الدفاع الذي عرف باسم
ميثاق الدفاع المجموعه ويعد التدشين
الحقيقي لنظام الامن الجماعي لاكواس
وحدد الحالات التي تستوجب التدخل كوجود
صراع يدار ويدعم من الخارج بما يهدد السلم
والامنال للمجموعه
كما نصت مادته 18 على ضروره وجود قوات
خاصه جاهزه للتدخل تشكل من خلال تعهد
الدول الاعضاء بوضع وحدات خاصه من قواتها
المسلحات تحت تصرف المجموعه في حاله اي
تدخل عسكري في عام
1999 وقعت اليه منع واداره وتسويه
الصراعات وحفظ السلام والامن وتضمنت اهم
بنودها توسيع قاعده تدخل قوات المجموعه في
الصراع الداخلي اذ شملت حالات مثل التهديد
بحدوث كارثه انسانيه ووجود اعمال عنف
تنتهك حقوق الانسان وحكم القانون بصوره
كبيره واطاحه حكومه المنتخبه وهو ما يمكن
الاستناد اليه في حاله النيجر وهي الحاله
التي لا تحظى حتى بتوافق داخل اكواس اذ
اظهرت كل من نيجيريا وكوت ديفوار حماسا
للتدخل العسكري في حين ابدت كل من السنغال
وبنين استعدادا للمشاركه في القوه
العسكريه الموجهه الى النيجر على الطرف
المقابل حذرت كل من مالي وبوركينا فاسو
وغينيا من ان اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر
سيكون بمثابه اعلان حرب عليها علما ان
عضويه تلك الدول المعلقه في اكواس نظرا
لسيطره مجالس عسكريه على السلطه هناك عبر
انقلابات وسبق لاكواس ان استخدمت قواتها
في عده دول اما على شكل قوات لحفظ السلام
كما حصل خلال الحرب الاهليه في كوت ديفوار
وليبيريا عام 2003 او من خلال تدخل عسكري
مباشر من اجل تسليم السلطه لرئيس المنتخب
وهو ما حدث في غامبيا عام 2017
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء نقلت صحيفه عن قياديا
عسكريا كبير في احدى دول مجموعه اكواس
توقعه ان اي تدخل عسكري لانهاء الانقلاب
في النيجر يحتاج الى تحضير يستغرق سته
اشهر واوضح القيادي العسكري ان قوه
الاحتياط التابعه عباره عن قشره فارغه حسب
تعبيره تحتاج الى التعبئه بالجنود والعتاد
ونقلت عن مسؤول دفاعي امريكي رفيع القول
ان التهديدات المضاده من مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وغينيا والقوات التي استولت على
السلطه في النيجر قد ترضع اكواس عن اتخاذ
اجراءات عسكريه واضافت نقلا عن مسؤول غربي
ان المجلس العسكري في النيجر عزز
الاجراءات الامنيه المفروضه على الرئيس
بازون بنحو 70 حارسا واشارت الصحيفه الى
ان الرئيس بازون ابلغ الرئيس الفرنسي
ووزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بان المجلس
العسكري قطع عنه الكهرباء وان الماء سينفذ
لديه في القريب
معنى من ابوجا الجنرال المتقاعد هنري
ايولا الرئيس السابق للتطوير الدفاعي
بوزاره الدفاع النيجيريه وزميل كليه
الدفاع الوطني في نيجيريا اهلا وسهلا بك
هل تعتقد بان الظروف مهيئه عسكريا لتدخل
من دول اكواس
السؤال اذا هو هل ان اكويس مستعده لتدخل
عسكري نعم سيدي
لا استطيع ان اقول بشيء انقاطع نعم او لا
انا لست مسؤولا في الاكواس والاك ما
استطيع قوله هو ان
الجاهزيه
لعمليه عسكريه تتطلب
توفر عناصر كثيره
اولها او علينا ان نفكر
بمدى
جاهزيه كل قوه عسكريه للدول الاعضاء
والحقيقه كم دوله من دول الاعضاء متجاهزه
ومستعده لكامل مثل هذا العمل العسكري اذا
ما اخذنا بنظر الاعتبار
ان الجيران ان الدول المجاوره للنيجر
هم يدعمون
الناجره انا اطلقنا معجبوا النادي الاعجاب
بوركينا
هذه كلها على نفس الوتيره اي انهم كلهم
يخضعون لحكم عسكري حاليا وبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان هؤلاء لديهم حسنه نوايا ويمكن ان
يشارك في اي قوه عسكريه وطبعا ان الحكومه
الدنيا ايضا هي ايضا
حكومه عسكريه وبالتالي هذا
يعني انه الاعضاء فقط خمسه دول من الاكواس
مستعد للعمل
عشره من المجموعه خمسه عشر وبالتالي ما هي
مدى جاهزيه قوات العسكريه هذه
وباي سرعه يمكن
تجنيد قواتهم وجعلها جاهزه لعمليات
العسكريه
وذلك لانها
هذا هذا يعني انه في نهايه هذا
البيان او المهله لان كل القوات العسكريه
للدول المعنيه لا وضعت في حاله انذار اي
انهم جاهزين للعمل
ولكن هل كان لديهم مثل هذه الجاهزه قبل
ذلك ولابد ايضا لا ننسى اننا نيجر نفسها
هي عضو من قوه العمل المشتركه الدوليه
وهي التي تتم اربع دول
كمساهمين في هذه القوه
وهناك الكثير من التفاهم بينهم ونيجيريا
وتشاد والكاميرون
وبالتالي
ايضا الجمهوريه ولكن فيما يتعلق بالجاهزيه
علينا ان ننظر للامر
ممكن احتماليه امكانيه قدرات هذه الدول
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا فعلا الكل يتحدث عن هذا الاحتمال
ومداه
نزوله الى الواقع شكرا لك الجنرال
المتقاعد من ابو شهم
قد تجمع الالاف من مؤيدين الانقلاب في
النيجر قرب القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه في
العاصمه نيامي ورفع المتظاهرون شعارات
المناهضه لباريس كما ردد هتافات ضدها وضد
منظمه ايكواس مراسلنا فضل عبد الرزاق رصد
هذه المظاهره
[موسيقى]
وقف هنا
يقف في هذا المكان من اجل التنديد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اولا تلك
المتعلمة
بعدها شريكا مهما يمكن الوثاق
وثقت به دول مجاوره كابوركينا فاسو ومالي
ولذلك الترحيب هنا هو بروسيا والتمديد هو
انسى والتي
[موسيقى]
اخرق الاج
واء سبق مع جماعات يقول المجلس العسكري
انها جماعات
مسله
[موسيقى]
هنا من اجل مهمه
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
ومعنا من يمي عمر الانصاري عضو المكتب
السياسي لحزب التجديد الديمقراطي
والجمهوري اهلا وسهلا بك هذا الذي تابعناه
والذي يوصف بتاييد شعبي لقاده الانقلاب هل
سيجعلهم اكثر
عنادا في التجاوب مع مطالب اكواس
نعم وهم اصلا لديهم عناد وارسلت لهم ولم
يقبلوها وهذا التعنت نحن ننتقده نحن
بالاحزاب السياسيه لانه يعني ارضيه
التفاوض لا بد منها فهم وان ايدهم الشعب
ليس شرعيون والشعب لم ينتهي من فقط الحزب
الحاكم حتى وان افترضنا تزبيرهم
للانتخابات وهو كونهم جاؤوا بغش انتخابي
فلديهم شعبيه في في مدن اخرى غير نيام فهم
حتى في اللانتخابات المزوره اقروا بانهم
خاسرين في نيابه وبان المعارضه هي التي
نجحت في فازت بنيامي بنسبه 80%
فاذا يعني كون بعض كون الشعبيه في نيام
وانصارهم في نيامي هذا لا يعني ان الشعب
النيجري هذا يمثل اراده الشعب النيجري ككل
نعم
ما زالت تلوح باستمرار بموضوع التدخل
العسكري هل تعتقد فعلا بان الامر يؤخذ
الان ماخذ الجد بفعل هذا التكرار
الامر سواء جد او هزل في امكانيه وقوعه هي
هي الاشكاليه يعني امكانيه الوقوع
والتحديات التي يواجهها على الواقع فعلا
انا اتفهم وضع الكواسم من ناحيه يعني
الهيبه ومن ناحيه
النظام وان ربما يتجرا جيوش اخرى على
الانقلابات في دول اخرى هذا كله هنا
تفاهمه ولكن في نفس الواقع على الايكو اس
ان تتفهم ان المنطقه مرتع للارهاب
والجريمه المنظمه
فحتى الان مع تكاتف الجهود من الجيوش
النظاميه وكذلك مساعديهم من الجيوش
الغربيه هناك فراغ فكيف اذا انقلبت هذه
الجيوش وبدات تتحارب فيما بينها فهذا يعني
يعني ان تسليم المنطقه
للارهاب ولجريمه المنظمه فهذا اعتقد ان
قناه يدركونه جيدا فلذلك امكانيه وقوع
التدخل العسكري هذه على الواقع صعبه جدا
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد عمر الانصاري يعود
المكتب السياسي لحزب التجديد الديمقراطي
والجمهوري من نيامي
[موسيقى]
في مستجدات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان طائره روسيه
من طراز 131 قصفت العاصمه
كما قال مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان روسيا اطلقت
صواريخ فرض صوتيه على منطقه ابن فرج
في غرب البلاد وقصفت مناطق القربى مطارا
عسكريا مما اسفر عن مقتل طفل في الثامنه
من جانبها اعلنت القوات الروسيه انها صدت
هجمات اوكرانيه وتمكنت من احراز تقدم في
مدينه كوبيانسك في شرقيه البلاد
في الاثناء اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني اليوم
اقاله رؤساء كل مراكز التجنيد العسكريه في
عموم البلاد على خلفيه دعاوى جنائيه تتعلق
بتهم فساد
لا تهتز كييف بالقصف الروسي وحده ثمه في
اروقه الاداره الاوكرانيه تفاعل وصراع من
نوع مختلف الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي راس الجمعه جلسه خاصه لمجلس
الامن القومي والدفاع وحسمه تصريح له تركز
الاجتماع على نتائج التفتيش على المفوضين
العسكريين او مسؤوليه تجنيد في عموم
البلاد كشف زيلينسكي عن اكثر من 100 دعوه
فساد جنائيه ضد اولئك المسؤولين العسكريين
وتحدث عن عشرات منهم تحت مستوى الشبهات
وقرر الاطاحه بهم جميعا
نحن نطرد جميع المفوضين العسكريين
الاقليميين يجب ان يدير هذا النظام اناس
يعرفون بالضبط ما هي الحرب ولماذا يشكل
التشكيك والرشوه في اوقات الحرب خيانه
محاربه الفساد مسار يستعجل به زيلينسكي
المزيد من مساعدات حلفائه الغربيين وتلك
عقده كانت بين الطرفين في ايام الحرب
وتبدو حاجه كييف متزايده لمزيد من العتاد
الغربي فتزامنا مع اقالات زيلينسكي قال
وزير خارجيته
المدى حاسمه وضروريه لانتصار بلاده وطلب
من الشركاء توفيرها في اقرب وقت توضع هذه
المناشدات في سياق صعوبات يواجهها الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي روجت له كييف طويلا
قبل حلول الصيف ولا يبدو انه اثمر كثيرا
صحيح ان المسيرات تصبح داخل الروسيه بشكل
شبهي واحدثها ما تحدث عنه عمده موسكو يوم
الجمعه لكن القوات الروسيه تحرز تقدما في
بعض الجبهات كخركيف التي بدات فيها
اوكرانيا مؤخرا عمليات اجلاء وتحديدا في
محيط كوبيا مسك ليس في خاركيف وحدها لكن
العقبات امام الهجوم المضاد مبثوثه على
طول خط التماس بين الجانبين المزروعي
بحقول الغام مت الطبقات تتفادى كييف عثرات
الهجوم المضاد باستنزاف الجيش الروسي
وخاصه طرق الامداد وبناها التحتيه لعل هذا
ما يفسر ايضا تكرار استهداف جسري القرم
اللذين يعول عليهما كثيرا الجيش الروسي في
امداداته واذاء الاستنزاف الاوكراني
استنزاف روسي مضاد يصوب نيرانه نحو العتاد
الغربي ويوسع نطاق شغل الطرف الاوكراني
بمواجهات ميدانيه تعوقه عن تركيز طاقته في
الهجوم المضاف
معنى من كييف اوليكس
المقارنه في جامعه كييف اهلا وسهلا بك هذه
ليست اول مره يجري فيها الحديث عن فساد في
اوكرانيا ما مدى خطورته في المؤسسه
العسكريه
يجب ان نكون هنالك مقاربه متوازنه بدايه
منذ
بدايه الغزو الروسيه فان الاوكران
تطوعوا في الجيش وكان هنالك عمليات تجنيد
في الجيش ومعظم الناس انضموا لاداء الواجب
الوطني لكن مع ذلك هنالك بعض الاشخاص
الذين حاولوا ان يهربوا من عمليات التجنيد
وحاولوا ان يفسدوا
ان يقوموا برشوه بعض نقاط التجنيد
العسكريه اذا من حسن الحظ حتى في وقت
الحرب وبحسب الاحكام العرفيه لدينا نظام
ديمقراطي ولدينا صحافه استقصائيه وكان
هنالك عرض لبعض الحالات الفساد وايضا
هؤلاء رؤساء نقاط التجنيد العسكريه تم
فضحهم وادانتهم اليوم كان هنالك قرار من
قبل الرئيس زينينسكي
لعزل كل رؤساء نقاط التجنيد العسكري على
المستوى الاقليمي بمعنى 25 شخصا لاين
لدينا نقاط التجنيد على مستويات ادنى ايضا
بالتالي هو اخذ هذا القرار
لاقاله كل هؤلاء القاده هذا القرار
يتم النظر اليه في المجتمع وهو مجتمع حر
بالتالي لدينا قدره على ان ننتقل ونناقش
كل ما يحدث الامور الشائكه لماذا لانه حتى
لو كان هنالك حالات فساد بالتالي هذه
الحالات كان يجب التحقيق في هذا الاشخاص
المتورطين يجب معاقبتهم لكن ان يتم عزل كل
الخمسه والعشرين
رئيسا يبدو وكان الامر
على انه قرار شعبوي بالتالي هذا هو
الملخص في بعض الاحيان الرئيس يرغب باتخاذ
قرارات سريعه يريد ان يظهر انه شخص حاسم
لديه قرارات صارمه نعم بعض الصحفيين هنا
في اوكرانيا
والخبراء علقوا على ان هذا الامر ربما هي
حركه من اجل كسب
الدعم الشعبي بالتالي ويريد ان يظهر يظهر
انه يحارب الفساد وهو امر جيد لكن عزل كل
هؤلاء الخمسه والعشرين شخصا من القاده
الاقليميين لنقاط التجديد
العسكريات يبدو وكانه مقاربه متوازنه شكرا
شكرا لك
كيف شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
سلطات في هواي عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى جراء
الحرائق في الجزر الى خمسه وخمسين شخصا
وكذلك ارتفاع عدد المفقودين الذي بلغ اكثر
من الف
وقد اتلفت النيران الاف البنيات ومساحات
خضراء شاسعه كما ادت الى انقطاع في التيار
الكهربائي عن اكثر من 11 الف مشترك
ومعنى من ولايه هاواي مراسل الجزيره شهاب
راتنسي ضعنا في سوره الوضع هناك
بعض الاخبار خلال الساعتين الاخيره فان
الحاكم قالت ان الناس المقيمين في لاهانيا
وهي مدينه تامه ان احترق بالكامل سيسمح
بالسكان بالعوده الى تلك المنطقه خلال
السنه وساعه ونصف القادمه كما تعرفونه
وترون نحن
مسافه بعيده لكن هذا هو صف السيارات
الممتاز الى
مدى النظر الناس الان يصطفون محاولين
العوده الى لهاينا من اجل رؤيه الضرر الذي
لحق بممتلكاتهم وما تبقى من لاهينا
الحاكمه قالت انه سيكون هنالك حظر تجوال
بين السادسه والتاسعه بالتالي
لا ينسى لدينا اعلان رسمي واكد هذا الامر
نتوقعه لكن السكان
يسمح لهم العوده الان يوم الخميس كان
هنالك بعض التوتر لان السلطات قالت انه لا
يمكنهم العوده لانه ليس هنالك كهرباء وليس
هنالك مياه ويحاولون جمع
البقايا الجثث وكان هنالك شعور بالغضب لدى
السكان لانهم كانوا يريدون العوده لرؤيه
ما حدث يبدو ان السلطات الان سمحت لهم
بالعوده اذا ما كان لديهم بطاقه هويه تثبت
انهم سكان في تلك المدينه وهذا الامر
سيبدا خلال الساعه ونصف القادمه شكرا لك
شهاب روتنسي من
[موسيقى]
السودان حيث صعد الجيش السوداني هجماته
على مواقع للدعم السريع بالخرطوم وام
درمان وولايه شمال كردفان وقالت الخارجيه
السودانيه ان خروج الدعم السريع من منازل
المواطنين هو شرط اساسي للعوده الى
التفاوض في الاثناء ناشدت الامم المتحده
جميع الاطراف توفير وصول امن للمساعدات
لجميع انحاء البلاد بما في ذلك كردفان
وتارفور
يوشك نزاع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع ان يكمل شهره الرابع دون اي مؤشرات
بقرب نهايته قالت مصادر عسكريه للجزيره ان
الجيش قصف من داخل قيادته تجمعات الدعم
السريع باحياء بوري والشاطئ والصفا
والرياض بشرق الخرطوم ومواقع اخرى في ام
درمان بينما شهد محيط سلاح المدرعات
التابع للجيش اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجانبين
في الوقت نفسه تستمر المعارك في ولايه
شمال كردفان وذكرت قياده الجيش هناك انها
هاجمت قوات الدعم في الطريق الرابط بين
المدينه ومنطقه بار الاستراتيجيه وان
الهجوم اسرى عن مصرع العشرات وذكرت ايضا
ان الطيران قصف مواقع ارتكازات الدعم
بمنطقه حمره الشيخ القريبه من الابيض ومع
استمرار القتال يتدهور الوضع الصحي وتحذر
الجهات الاغاثيه من اقتراب البلاد اكثر
فاكثر من كارثه صحيه شامله حيث يشكل فصل
الامطار الراهن تهديدا كبيرا لغالبيه
المناطق المكتويه بجحيم النزاع بل يتعدى
الخطر تلك المناطق ليتهدد المواقع التي
لاذ بها الاف الفارينه من القتال ووصفت
مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
سامانثى باور ان وضع في عموم السودان بانه
مدمر وان الوضع الانسانيه خاصه كارثي مدير
مركز غسيل الكلى في مدينه الدامر شمال
الخرطوم والتي نزح اليها الاف المرضى حذر
بان المركز يكاد يتوقف بسبب نفاذ المواد
اللازمه للغسيل مما سيفاقم من حاله المرضى
وناشد المنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه بسرعه
التدخل
وغير بعيد عن الموضوع تقول منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود ان القتال ادى الى خروج ثلاثه
ارباع المؤسسات الصحيه من الخدمه وان صراع
الجيش والدعم السريع يعيق دخول الكوادر
الصحيه الاجنبيه للبلاد ويعيق انتقالهم في
الداخل في حال دخولهم ولا يزال التقارب
بين الجانبين منعدما الخارجيه السودانيه
قالت في احدث تصريحاتها ان الحديث في
الساحه السودانيه حاليا ليس عن مفاوضات
وانما عن انهاء تمرد الدعم السريع وان
خروج الدعم من منازل المواطنين شرط اساسي
وموقف عام في حال العوده للتفاوض وكانت
دعم السريع قد رفض اكثر من مره اتهامه
بدخول منازل المواطنين ويقول ان عقده
النزاع تكمن في بقاء قياده الجيش الراهنه
وان القتال لا ينتهي الا بذهابهم
[موسيقى]
بعد غياب عندما سبعه واربعين عاما اطلقت
روسيا اول مسبار الى القمر في مهمه تهدف
الى البحث عن المياه واعطاء زخم جديد
لقطاعها الفضائي المتعثر منذ سنوات اقلع
الصاروخ سويوز الذي يحمل المسبار لونا 25
من قاعده
على بعد خمسه الاف وخمسمائه الى الشرق
بالموسكو ومن المقرر ان تصل المركبه
الفضائيه الى مدار القمر في غضون خمسه
ايام وستبقى في هذا المدار بين ثلاثه
وسبعه ايام لاختيار المكان المناسب قبل
الهبوطي في منطقه القطب الجنوبيه للقمر
استنادا لاحد كبار المسؤولين في وكاله
الفضاء الروسيه هذه اول مره سيكون فيها
الهبوط في القطب الجنوبي للقمر وهي منطقه
يعتقد انها تحتوي على رواسب من الجليد
المائي كل المهمات السابقه هبطت في
المنطقه الاستوائيه
اشارت الوكاله الى ان المركبه التي ستبقى
على سطح القمر لمده عام ستكون مهمتها اخذ
عينات وتحليل التربه وكذلك اجراء ابحاث
علميه طويله المدى وعد الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين بمواصله برنامج الفضاء الروسي على
الرغم من العقوبات الغربيه المفروضه على
بلاده متذكرا انا التي حدث سوف ياتي ارسل
اول رجل الى الفضاء عام 61
و900 وسط تصاعد التوتر انذاك بين الشرق
والغرب
وتسابق المهمه الروسيه الحاليه الزمن مع
مهمه للهند التي اطلقت مركبه مركبه الهبوط
على القمر شندريان ثلاثه الشهر الماضي كما
تتنافس كذلك على نطاق اوسع مع الولايات
المتحده والصين اللتين لديهما برامج
متقدمه باستكشاف القمر تستهدف القطب
الجنوبيه عادت اخر مهمه سفياتيه الى القمر
وهي لونا 24 في عام 76 الف بعينات من
التربه عادت بها الى الارض ويعد قطاع
الفضاء مصدر فخر كبير لروسيا فالسوفيات
اطلقوا اول قمرا صناعي وهو سبوتنيك
وارسلوا اول حيوان هي الكلبه لايكا الى
مدار الارض ثم اول رجل وهو يوري جاجرين
واول امراه هي فالنتينا تيرشكوفا ولكن
الولايات المتحده تفوقت هي الاخرى على
الاتحاد السوفيتي بارسالها اول رجل هبط
على سطح القمر هو النيل ارمسترونج في
يوليو عام 69 و900
معنى من لوس انجلوس الدكتور عصام حجي عالم
الفضاء في وكاله ناسا اهلا وسهلا بك هذا
التسابق الدولي على القمر ان صح التعبير
ما فائدته العلميه الحقيقيه
الفائده العلميه هنا بوضوح هي الاستغناء
عن المحطه الفضاء المداريه التي تحيط
بكوكب الارض وهي المحطه الدوليه وتعويضها
بمحطات تكون موجوده على سطح القمر اذا
نظرنا لقائمه الدول التي تتسابق للهبوط في
المنطقه الجنوبيه من سطح القمر والتي
يعتقد وجود فيها كميات من المياه والجليد
تساعد في اقامه محطات دائمه تقريبا هي نفس
الدول الكبرى المشاركه في المحطه الدوليه
التي اصبحت تكلفه وجودها تكلفه عاليه
وايضا عمليه تشغيلها
تتضارب مع المصالح الدوليه والعلاقات
الدوليه مثل ما راينا في اثار
العمل في هذه المحطه كثره الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه وتوقف الرحلات الروسيه
للامداد الى المحطه الدوليه وتعويضها
بالمحطه برحلات الامداد ليه الشركات
الامريكيه مثل سبيس اكس اذا الوصول
للقطبه الجنوبي للقمر هو بدايه وجود
الانسان في محطات داءمه
خارج كوكب الارض سواء لمراقبه التغيرات
المناخيه او سواء لمراقبه كوكب الارض بشكل
عام واجراء بعض التجارب العلميه التي التي
لا يمكن ان نقوم بها على كوكب الارض نتيجه
وجود غلاف الجوي واشاعات اخرى عندما نقول
القطب القطب الجنوبي للقمر وانت تشير الى
اهميته ما الذي يجعله مغايرا للتجارب
السابقه في موضوع القمر والنزول حتى على
سطح القمر
اهميه القطب الجنوبي هو اكثر منطقه على
سطح القمر بها كميات من الجليد المؤكده
حتى هذا اليوم اذا من سيستطيع الوصول
وتحديد اماكن واعماق هذا الجليد تستطيع ان
يقوم بانشاء محطات
علميه دائمه على سطح القمر وهنا يجب ان
نرى الصراع بشكل واضح انه لا يوجد من عهده
لتقسيم حقوق البقاء على سطح القمر مثل
المعاهدات الموجوده في القطب الجنوبي
لكوكب الارض الذي يستخدم من استخدامات
العلميه السلميه اذا السباق الحالي هو من
سيسيطر على هذه البقعه وينتفع منها
للتجارب العلميه ونرى هنا النزاعات الفضاء
الكبرى مثل ناسا والوكاله فضاء الصينيه
والهنديه والروسيه واليابانيه وايضا
راينا تعاون مع دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده التي تتعاونك الفضاء اليابانيه في
هذا الهدف هناك حديث الان هذه المره عن
معادن نادره في القمر يمكن الاستفاده منها
ليس فقط بحوث علميه ولكن ايضا معادن ما
مدى دقه مثل هذه المعلومه
اعتقد عمليه تعدين الكواكب ليست بهذه
السهوله لانه التكلفه ارسال كيلو جرام
واحد من الماده من كوكب الارض
الى القمر مكلف وعودته مكلف اكثر عشره
اضعاف ما يتكلفه الارسال فعمليه التعدين
تهدف فقط لاستخدام هذه المعادن على سطح
القمر لانشاء محطات الدائمه التي ستكون هي
مراصد نرى بها الكون تعوض المحطه المداريه
وتعوض التلسكوبات التي ايضا نقوم بارسالها
في اماكن بعيده الفضاء بشكل مبسط
نوعا ما هذه المحطات الدائمه سيكون فيها
الاكثر ربوات وليس الانسان اليس كذلك
هذا ما لا يعرف بعد يعني هناك سؤال دائما
يطرح نفسه ويطرحه الناس لماذا لا يمكن
لماذا لم نرسل انسان على القمر بعد اكثر
من 45 عام من انزال الانسان على سطح القمر
والاجابه هو مع حضرتك بقى افدت به انه من
45 عام يوجد انسان الي فكان الانسان اكثر
الكفاءه في جمع العينات والصور والفهم
اليوم الانسان يستطيع ان يقوم بكل ما يقوم
به عشرات البشر اذا لم يذهب انسان للقمر
ليس لانه من المستحيل او الصعب بل لانه لا
معنى علميا ولا جدوى علميه من ذلك لان
روبوتات تقوم بذلك المحطات الدائمه ستكون
اغلبها في رايي ستعمل بالمنظومات الاليه
والمراصد الاليه وستستخدم الذكاء الصناعي
وسيكون التواجد العنصر
فشري فيها محدود لبعض التجارب التي لا
يمكن للاليات ان تقوم بها حتى هذا اليوم
هذا التنافس الذي الدوله الذي اشرنا اليه
هل يخشى منه طالما انه لا توجد نصوص تنظم
العمليه بين كل هذه القوه على الاقل نصوص
يعترف بها الجميع
ما يخشى منه انه من سيستطيع السيطره على
الابحاث العلميه في في سطح القمر فيستطيع
السيطره على رصد كل ما يدور في كوكب الارض
لانه يستطيع القيام بمراصد تقوم برصد
التحركات على على السطح بدقه عاليه
باستخدام المراصد الكبيره الحجم التي لا
يمكن ان نضعها على الاقمار الصناعيه في
الوقت الحالي اذا يعني هناك بعض من
المخاطر لهذه العمليه ولذلك
كانت الرؤيه الامريكيه هنا في مشروع
هارتيمس ان لا يكون مشروع المتحده فقط بل
يكون بمشاركه دوليه وتمت
امداد الدعوه العديد من الدول العالم التي
ليس لها مشروعات فضاء للمساهمه في مشروع
ارتيمس شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عصام حجي عالم
الفضاء في وكاله ناسا وانت معنا من لوس
انجلوس
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الامم المتحده انتهاء عمليه سحب
حموله ناقله النفط صافر المتداعيه قباله
ميناء الحديده اليمني في البحر الاحمر
واشارت المنظمه الدوليه الى سحب اكثر من
مليون برميل نفط منها بذلك تم تفادي كارثه
طبيعيه حيث زال الخطر الذي كان وشيكا وقد
سادت لفتره مخاوف من حصول تسرب قد يدفع
حمولتها الى البحر الاحمر
اذا انتهت عمليه سحب حموله ناقله النفط
سافر المهجوره الراسيه منذ سنوات قباله
ميناء الحديده اليمنيه الاستراتيجي في
البحر الاحمر وقد استغرق نقل اكثر من
مليون برميل من خامي مارب الخفيف الى
السفينه الجديده اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع
ترسوا سافر التي صنعت قبل 37 عاما وتستخدم
منصه لتخزين عائمه على بعد نحو 50
كيلومترا من ميناء الحديده الاستراتيجي
ونظرا لموقع السفينه في البحر الاحمر فان
اي تسرب قد يكلف مليارات الدولارات يوميا
اذ سيتسبب باضطرابات في مسارات الشحن بين
مضيق باب المندب وقناه السويس وفي مارس
اذار الماضي اشترت الامم المتحده السفينه
نوتيكا بهدف سحب الحموله ويتنازع طرفا
النزاع اليمني ملكيه النفط والسفينه التي
سيتم تغيير اسمها ليصبح هو اليمن وقد
اعربت السعوديه عن ترحيبها باعلان الامم
المتحده حيال اكتمال سحب النفط الخام من
الخزان العام صافر قباله سواحل اليمن وتمت
الخارجيه والسعوديه في بيان لها جوده او
جهود الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
وفريق العمل الذين عملوا على تسخير جميع
الجهود لاهنهائي هذه المشكله مشكله الخزان
معبره عن تقديرها للدعم المالي السخي من
الدول المانحه على ما قدمته من منح ماليه
وتبرعات لانهاء تهديد الخزان على
واشار بيان الخارجيه السعوديه الى ان رياض
كانت من اوائل الدول المانحه من خلال مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
وذلك ضمن جهودها مع المجتمع الدولي لحل
المشكله
كما قدمت الخارجيه السعوديه الشكر لقياده
تحالف دعم الشرعيه في اليمن على ما قدمته
من دعم لتسهيل عمليه الخطه التشغيليه حتى
الانتهاء من تفريخ الخزان
[موسيقى]
كل شيء كان احمر الغبار والرياح في كل
مكان كثيفه كالجحيم ظننت انني ساموت هي
لحظات صعبه يرويها احد النجين من حريق
هاواي الذي ضرب تحديدا مدينه لهااينا في
جزيره ماوي والتي مسحت تقريبا من الخريطه
اودت الحرائق المروعه بحياه 55 شخصا على
الاقل في هذه الولايه الامريكيه كما اتت
النيران على متاجر الهدايا والمطاعم وكذلك
المعالم التاريخيه يضيف احد السكان ما
زلنا نرى جثه تطفو على المياه وفي السدود
بعدما القى العديد من السكان بانفسهم في
البحر حين حاصرتهم النيران يقول الخبراء
ان الحرائق ليست امرا غير معتاد في هاواي
الا انها هذه المره امتدت على مساحه اكبر
من المعتاد وكان انتشار النيران سريعا
والسنه اللهب عاليه
تمت عوامل اخرى بالطبع ادت الى اندلاع
حرائق هذا العام بينها النباتات الشديده
الجفاف وسقوط امطار اقل من المتوسط خلال
الربيع وكذلك درجات الحراره والتي كانت
اعلى من المعتاد ندعو للجميع بالنجاه مما
وصفت باسوء كارثه طبيعيه في تاريخ ولايه
هاواي بهذا نصل الى ختام حصاد الليله الان
الى جوله منتصف الليل التي يسحبنا فيها
تسحبنا فيها وسيله علمي وجلال شهده مشاهده
ممتعه مع بقيه فقراتنا الاخبا